[Música]
después de estar momento de paz y
tranquilidad hablamos como la espalda de
mercados el día de hoy está con nosotros
jorge hurtado de la redacción de
economía jorge buenas noches comencemos
con los resultados de la visita del
príncipe heredero de arabia saudita
mohamed bin salman a la ciudad del cairo
la capital de egipto es que egipto y
arabia saudita firmaron al menos 14
acuerdos de inversión con un valor de
7.700 millones de dólares los acuerdos
abarcan sectores como infraestructura
proyectos de energía renovable hidrógeno
verde medicina y comercio electrónico el
anuncio se da en el segundo día de la
visita del príncipe heredero saudí al
país como parte de la gira en turquía y
jordania y que se da también en el
contexto de la primera visita el
presidente de eeuu joe biden arabia
saudita previsto para el 15 y el 16 de
julio egipto ha sido afectado por el
incremento de los precios globales de
los alimentos como consecuencia de la
guerra en ucrania y se lanzó a la
búsqueda de inversores internacionales
para atraer divisas y apuntar a repuntar
su economía el gobierno de egipto
negocia ahora un nuevo préstamo con el
fondo monetario internacional para
afrontar sus problemas económicos
pasemos ahora a hablar de rusia porque
pese a que hay varias sanciones
internacionales por la invasión a rusia
a ucrania parece que la industria minera
particularmente la de los metales
preciosos se mantiene así es y uno de
los actores principales jesuita que
importó oro de rusia por primera vez
desde la invasión de ucrania la
administración federal de aduana suiza
reveló que más de tres toneladas de oro
fueron enviadas a suiza desde rusia en
mayo pasado la importación la primera
vez es la guerra podría hacer un cambio
en la percepción de los lingotes rusos
que fueron ampliamente rechazados tras
la invasión a ucrania los refinadores
dejaron de comprar oro nuevos
procedentes de rusia después de que una
importante asociación inglesa eliminar a
los fabricantes rusos de su lista de
acreditados suiza alberga cuatro grandes
refinerías de oro que en conjunto
manejan dos tercios del oro mundial en
marzo dos grandes refinerías de oro se
negaron a refundir lingotes ruso pese a
que las normas del mercado les permiten
hacerlo y pasamos ahora al reino unido
en donde hubo caos después de que fuera
anunciada la mayor huelga de los trenes
del servicio de atracciones en 30 años
adelantarte que esta huelga se va a
repetir el próximo jueves y el sábado y
los sindicatos no descartan nuevas
acciones si no llegan a un acuerdo de
salarios y condiciones laborales al
menos 50.000 miembros del sindicato
ferroviario rm t se declararán en huelga
durante tres días de esta semana decenas
de estaciones de trenes y metro de
londres cerraron o trabajaron de forma
parcial debido a esta huelga y pasamos a
colombia para hablar sobre las
reacciones de las bolsas los mercados
allí después de que gustavo petro fuera
electo presidente de ese país asumirá el
7 de agosto un dato santiago la bolsa
colombiana fue de toda la población
mundial es la que más cayó el día de hoy
como era de esperarse los mercados
dieron la primera señal de cómo
interpretan este resultado electoral
realizando ventas masivas de acciones
este fenómeno lo vimos recientemente en
la bolsa de valores de chile tras la
victoria de gabriel boric el índice de
culpa de la bolsa de valores de colombia
retrocedió hasta el 5 por ciento pero
luego se moderó y cerró con pérdidas que
rondaba en el 3 por ciento la empresa
que llevó la peor parte fue ecopetrol la
más importante en el mercado de valores
colombiano esto por el cambio en las
políticas de materias qué anuncio petro
durante su campaña ya que quiere pasar
de una economía extractivista hacia una
economía productiva así como frenar
nuevas exploraciones petroleras en el
país las acciones de ecopetrol muestran
números rojos desde hace meses
precisamente por este temor que generaba
el programa de petro frente a la
explotación de petróleo ahora los
inversores se mantienen a la expectativa
de las personas que nombraría petro para
liderar su equipo económico esto podría
generar calma y ratificar lo que
prometió en su toma de posesión donde
dijo que iba a desarrollar el
capitalismo en colombia escuchamos y que
dicen los analistas al respecto
vamos a observar una reacción inicial
donde probablemente los activos como
está sucediendo el día de hoy muestran
pérdidas en las primeras dos o tres
jornadas y allí en adelante creemos que
vamos a ver un descanso estaremos por
supuesto muy pendientes de englobar los
anuncios por parte del gobierno pero en
general vamos a empezar a converger un
poco más a los estructurales a los
fundamentales que tiene la economía
colombiana que en estos momentos son
positivos y era de esperarse que hubiera
un choque inicial bastante fuerte a la
administración de gustavo petro esto no
quiere decir que haya un pánico
financiero o un pánico económico que
esté desatándose en este momento lo que
sí significa es nerviosismo y ese
nerviosismo se traduce en un cambio de
manos del dinero un cambio de manos de
las acciones y eso trae una volatilidad
del mercado pasamos ahora los
indicadores como las ffaa las otras
bolsas en el resto del mundo bueno en
eeuu los principales índices de wall
street subieron más de un 2 por ciento
ya que los inversores compraron acciones
de empresas energéticas en europa la
renta variable subió por tercera sesión
consecutiva impulsada por los sectores
químicos y de materias primas en américa
latina' ya lo mencionamos los mercados
colombianos sufrieron las peores caídas
tras la victoria de gustavo petro una
situación lógica por las incógnitas que
aún no despeja sobre el futuro gabinete
jorge muchas gracias por esta
actualización y las noticias del mundo
de la economía a continuación en directo
américa al debate